grab your pumpkin spice lattes everybody
entertaining expert paul zhan is back
and helping us fall into the season with
some must-have items take a look
paul welcome back thank you so much for
having me and happy fall
happy fun i can't believe we're here we
finally made it
it's it's crazy how time is flying right
now but of course we need to get
ourselves
in fall gear and get everything we need
exactly i have everything we need to
really win this fall
including first up we're going to talk
fall skincare
i have some olay regenerist micro
sculpting cream that will help you know
refine those
fine lines and wrinkles and really give
you a lot of moisturizer
because we really want to get the skin
moist especially in las vegas where it's
super dry
so in this little jar of layer generous
cream
we have as much vitamin b3 as
2500 cups of kale now this is just one
cup
imagine this times 2500 that's how much
vitamin b3 is in this olay regenerous
cream which will help
you know give you that dewy jlo glow and
you can find out more information at
olay.com doesn't this sound fun
i love that that's what we need next up
we want to talk a little bit about fall
home and fashion essentials with jc
penney
so jcpenney has so many great items
including fashion
including gym clothes including home
decor for fall
at a really great value and they're
doing curbside contact
less pickup so if you go to jcp.com
order some stuff
swing by just pop it into your trunk so
let's chat a little bit about the
fashion
i mean it's not fall unless we have a
pumpkin colored shirt right
or some denim or some lovely little
booties right here so
jc penney really has everything you need
i also picked up some candles because
hello we need pumpkin candles for
fall isn't that right pumpkin everything
for fun
pumpkin everything exactly
speaking of everything we are getting
rid of those complicated
and costly meals with home chef meal
kits so home chef meal kits just
launched their
affordable meal kits so let's talk a
little bit about the cost on these
pre-packaged pre-portioned meals that
are super easy a meal for two starts at
12.99
a meal for four starts at 17.99 these
are available at smith's or you can go
to homechef.com
to sort out your own customizable
delicious cuisine
by home chef and um we're taking the
guessing work out of dinners
and everything with home chefs wow
especially now the school's back in
session
kids are at home that makes it very
convenient
i love that exactly exactly speaking of
kids being at home
with everybody spending more time at
home more time on their computers
we have motorola tech three three and
one true
wireless earbuds so let's chat a little
bit about this three-in-one situation so
first up
we have the earbuds that you know you
can pop in your ear if you're
you know walking around doing conference
calls then
we also have a sports loop that actually
can loop around and connect if you're
going for a run
if you're working out it's perfect for
that what is your favorite thing about
the fall season
pumpkin spice latte is hello i know
mine has to be the sweater dresses and
boots
i can't wait to wear sweater and boots
again i'm gonna put on a sweater dress
this year and i will think of you